One way of composing policies is to
perform both operations simultaneously. For example, one might
want to forward traffic but also count how
much traffic is being forwarded. Both of those
operations can be performed in parallel. Another
way of composing policies is in sequence. Sequential
composition performs one operation then the next. For
example, we might want to implement a firewall.
And whatever traffic makes it though the firewall
might then be subjected to the switching policy.
One example of sequential composition, might be a
load balancer. In this example, a policy might
take some traffic coming from, half of the
source IP addresses, and rewrite that to one
server replica and take the other half of
the traffic and rewrite it to the other replica.
After the load balancer rewrites the destination
IP address, we need a routing module to
forward the traffic out the appropriate port on
the switch. In this case, we've used sequential
composition to first apply a load balance policy
that rewrites the destination IP address based on
the source IP address where the traffic is
coming from and sequentially apply a routing policy
that forwards the traffic out the appropriate
port. Depending on the resulting destination IP
address after that rewrite has taken place. Notice that we can use predicates to
specify which traffic traverses which modules. Those
predicates can apply specific actions based on
things like the input port and the packet header fields. The ability to compose
policies in this fashion allows each module
to partially specify functionality without having to write
the policy for the entire network. This
leaves some flexibility so that one module can
implement a small bit of the network
function, leaving some functions for other modules. This
also allows for module re-use, since a module need not be tied to a particular
network setting. For example, in this particular
example where we've applied that load balancer
followed by routing, the load balancer spreads
traffic across the replicas without regard to the
underlying network paths that traffic takes once
those destination IP addresses are rewritten. In summary,
we've covered two concepts. One is the notion of a Northbound API, which sits on
top of an SDN controller and provides and exposes higher level abstractions that
allows the operator or programmer to write policies without regard to how open
flow rules eventually get installed. We've
also talked about two different composition operators.
Parallel composition and sequential composition, which specify
how individual simpler policies can be composed
to implement more complex network applications, thus allowing different SDN
control programs to independently perform tasks on the same traffic.